there's a term called dramatic irony
a dramatic irony has to do with what the
audience knows it has to do with who has
information so the audience can know
something that the characters don't know
like that someone has a gun when they
walk in the room and it creates suspense
the characters can know things that
other characters don't know I find this
to be the most exciting dramatic tool
especially when you you know this is
what creates tension for me when we were
got to a point where I could write a
scene and I did it for fun in a way to
see if it was possible and how long it
could go on where Lane Price's character
promotes two people to the same job they
don't know that each other have both
been given the job so they think the
other one has not gotten the job and
they get in the elevator together and
they are being magnanimous they are
they're trying not to brag and they're
saying like you've always been there for
me because I got the job and everyone
goes I want you to know that you'll
always be a big part and they're just
doing this and neither one of them knows
that they both have the same shitty job